johnny johnny depp won 15 million
dollars five million of it was for
punitive damages
somehow amber
won two million dollars
and it was for
the the lawyer camille vasquez
apparently defaming her i don't believe
it was camille vasquez because i said
that that was a different lawyer a
different lawyer adam yeah that's a
different guy let's leave adam out of
this i understand adam's a good guy
he wouldn't defame nobody let's have a
little respect for adam it was not his
current lawyers it was a it was a couple
years ago a different lawyer it wouldn't
have okay gotcha so not so but net how
much does johnny win here
so apparently he's walking away with
because people do the math and think
it's 13. he's walking away with only
eight points something because kelly you
said that so
he won 10 million dollars in
compensatory damages but the 5 million
that's uh
uh the punitive damages the state law
caps it at 350 000. so he really only
won and overall 10.35 million dollars
and they're in virginia right this court
is in virginia the club wherever the
washington post headquarters is oh yeah
fairfax i think it's yet sir
kelly on the ball so he's walking away
with a little over 10 million dollars
yes and now i don't expect you to know
this answer but she doesn't even have 10
million dollars well she or she i think
she does because she won she wants well
she got seven when they got divorced
she's been in aquaman too
she's not investing or not doing the
stuff that you guys talk about on your
money yeah if shane listen to the sauce
money yeah i mean but uh i mean dude she
has to pay up though right or else you
got you don't you get anything she
wasn't she gifted money from elon musk
or johnny depp what she owed to some
organ
organization do you remember that so do
you think she ends up paying this how's
that going to work out she's she was on
him right now she owns like 20 million
dollars google amber heard net worth
which is not i don't really believe it
she had it
[ __ ] in johnny depp's bed she better pay
the goddamn money bro you don't [ __ ] in
somebody's bag i'm sorry that's what
drew the line that right were right
there because nobody ever got went into
like i wanted nobody went to death no
pun intended was he sleeping and she
just squatted in like ninja [ __ ]
no adam how do you [ __ ] because he just
rolled over and picked up the sheets and
and it wasn't it wasn't chihuahua [ __ ]
it was a human being [ __ ] i want to know
the particulars how you because she only
did it once and he was out of town how
do you know what if she only didn't talk
about it no no no no she only did it
once then so okay then you know what you
don't know nine million what are you
about to say natalia no they said that
um when she did it he
she had went um
to coachella with her friends that
weekend and he so they got a fight and
he left and then she
went to she was going to coachella so
before she went to coachella she did
that activity
and so he figured that at that time it
would be the right time to go home and
get his stuff you know because she was
out of the house
and i forgot who so don't quote me um
but they said like hey like i don't
think you should go home like now is
probably not a good time and he's like
what do you mean so then that's when he
went home and he was and then he found
so her and her friends are getting ready
to go to coachella she's getting her
shirts and [ __ ] and she's just like just
give me ten more seconds he's gonna know
do you think she actually did that
100 surprise i feel like is anybody
surprised if she actually did that
go ahead go ahead kelly she could have
been like i'm just going to do this to
prove a point and like not intending for
like anybody to actually see that but
like you know people try to validate
themselves
i've been in so many fights with
girlfriends yeah
half my friends are in dysfunctional
relationships
vinnie's been abused by certain women i
don't want to couple them out there
this has never been a topic we've
discussed never this has never been a
thing never vinnie's using terms like
ninja [ __ ] this is not a thing right in
the pop culture nomenclature this is not
a thing
what is going on with them they're
drinking there's some drugs i was
drinking
coachella's cocaine and molly bro i
don't listen to me if you've ever
dabbled and molly or whatever when it
hits you're taking a [ __ ]
okay so nobody's putting this but do you
think because they were so-called like
in love and passionate like i feel like
sometimes when somebody that maybe you
have a strong feeling towards like
because you have that strong feeling it
also gives you the realm to like when
you're angry be like even more angry
than like yeah it's amplified so like i
not surprised she like [ __ ] in his bed
that's insane i've never heard her i've
never heard her she may have been
because that's gonna be a move watch
this now that this is out there that's a
move yeah we broke up and you know what
i did next
gentlemen wash your sheets take care of
your pillowcases you don't know what's
going on out there this is what amber
hurt has done for society by the way
amber heard's net worth is up for debate
allegedly fox business reports that it's
eight million eight million dollars
twelve point three million that's gone
that's a range i guess we're celebrating
that never new zealand heroes so they're
converting okay gotcha i got you
so listen
somewhere between five and 12 million
dollars meaning if she does have to pay
this 10 million dollars because i assume
that's what happens when you
lose a lawsuit
she's going to be she's does she is her
career
ever come back from this she if she
starts an old b let's be real great
question if she starts an only fans
today she'll be making like that bad
that bad barbie girl made her money bad
baby she'd be the number one only fans
girls amber i'll bet a one
mil 100 yeah she started the only fans
page she'd
and yo she could [ __ ] on it and she
would make money but do you think she
would be popular because of
like oh we we want to see her or like oh
let's look at this